now Reese you got an advanced copy of
the book who was the one who kind of put
it in your lap and said you need to read
this and make it into a movie was
actually I'm Cheryl Cheryl reached out
to me through my agent and hurt through
her book agent I could off and she four
months before the book was published and
they asked her you know who she wanted
to send the book to and she said why I
really like to have Reese play me in a
movie and so she sent it to me and I was
just kind of thinking about starting a
production company because I was kind of
feeling like I didn't love a lot of the
things i was reading for women out there
um and I read it in 48 hours I was just
in a puddle of tears but happy tears
because I think it's a very hopeful
movie and I it was midnight and I calm
age and I said I don't know who this
woman is but I have to talk to her
tomorrow and they got me her number and
I called her and I just said beyond ever
making up this into a movie this is one
of the most beautiful books I've ever
read in my entire life and you're going
to change people's lives it's going to
give people hope where they have none
and and then it took her about seven
days I told her what kind of movie I
wouldn't want to make and she called me
seven days later and said okay I'm gonna
let you up to my book so did she ever
tell you why she wanted you to play her
yeah I asked her I said dude i love this
is amazing but why do you want me to do
it and she said well you don't know but
we actually kind of look alike and she
said and the other thing you can't
really tell from the book but i'm really
funny and she is she's this wonderful
warm funny woman and we actually have a
lot in common actually as actors what
was it like to have her as a resource
every day on set was an intimidating did
you embrace the opportunity to just ask
her questions non-stop yeah absolutely i
mean that you there is there is no
greater resource she was our touchstone
you know even at any given moment if I
sort of felt myself wandering or if I
started to get up in my head about
things that frankly you don't need to be
in your head about you know technical
stuff or worrying about whether or not
I'm showing up in the right way or any
of that stuff I just had to turn around
and Cheryl was there and you just
remember immediately and intimately why
you're making what you're making and she
was she was she was the emotional
touchstone she was she was our great
sort of integrity generator yeah I mean
she was there husband was there her
daughter is actually plays the young
version of her in the film so that's her
daughter and her daughter was working
with Laura and so it was just it was
very much a family affair and we all
became very close and you know and we
all had dinner all the time I still do
have too much wine and cry because she
is so involved in the process was it was
it less nerve-wracking to finally show
her the final product oh no that was
probably one of the scariest days my
professional life was showing her the
film about her life and her beautiful
book that I just did not want to mess up
and we SAT there it was brunette I and
jean-marc and and Cheryl and her husband
and we are on a editing suite in at on
Fox to do lots and and we were all just
watching her and I kind of worried and
then she's you know had to get a tissue
and she was sort of you know and then
she got to the end of it and she was
just beautiful and she hugged all of us
and she looked at me and she said I saw
your words written I saw my words
written on your face and it was the
biggest compliment I've ever had you
know professionally in my life because
all I wanted to do was right by her as I
want to get a producers perspective on
this i mean the book is not inherently
cinematic you know it's this woman
walking a lot and thinking a lot out
loud not out loud but you know in Erin
were you nervous about kind of
overcoming that to make the film as
cinematic as it actually turned out um
no it's strangely i wasn't i mean when i
read i think that the benchmark for me
because people always say well woody
what do you look for and when i read
something and it doesn't feel firstly
when it's
beautiful writing it's just like you
want to keep reading and then when it
doesn't feel like something I've seen
that excites me I produced a movie
called warm bodies which you know is all
from the person doesn't speak you know
at the center of it and for me it's like
if something if I if I can't find the
words to compare it to something else
than that you're onto a good thing and
then we knew we had to find a very deaf
screenwriter to be able to kind of
impose a structure on this you know as a
dramatic piece because obviously that
had to live in its own world and he just
the second we sat down with the quantity
he had a kind of emotional architecture
for how he would do that and he did it
like I mean he religiously delivered a
script within 10 weeks that was exactly
what he had told us he would do and it
was brilliant you know so I love the
challenge of it and what John Mark then
I think then of course your choice
becomes about the right an exciting
filmmaker who has great craft and one of
the things that John Mark and reason I
talked a lot about is how memory works
and and she describes it so well in her
book and we don't memory doesn't you
know we often all seen movies where
memory has played back into these long
flashbacks and it's not really how
memory works it works in pieces and so
he really bought that to to what you
know the movie you just saw and he would
find those moments that weren't scripted
often just find them on the day knowing
that he would you know craft that
emotional sequence together in his head
so I found it exciting so reason behind
starting up this production company was
it initially because you know you saw a
lack of great female roles out there and
you wanted to create films for yourself
for Laura for other actresses you know
to inhabit these roles yeah about three
years ago I was taking out a comedy
pitch to all the different studios and
so I SAT with each head of the studio
and I talked to him in like 30 minutes
about what else they were developing for
women and literally all the studios
except for one we're developing so we're
developing nothing for a woman for a
female lead and I was kind of astounded
I'd go either the I think for three
so I went to every dinner party going do
you know they're not developing any
female leads at blankety-blank studio
blanket I mean can you believe that and
you know eventually started complaining
so much about it my husband said I mean
are you going to just complain about
this are you going to do something about
it because I know you and you're like
the kind of person who you see a problem
you fix it so he's like why don't you
you know do this and that encouragement
meant everything to me and then then I
got wild and i bought wild with my own
money and I was like oh my god I have
this amazing book now what do I do and
that's when I called bruna and I said I
really want to start this production
company and it's not about developing
projects just for me I want to develop
projects for all these amazing women
that we both know and to which I just
want to see complex dynamic women
because I just am not reading them and
she was like okay well let me think
about it she told me she would think
about it and probably like seven months
later she called me and she said okay no
know exactly how it happened to is that
her wild but it's a better story this
way but I said her she was like oh we
were talking about it and then I got
wild and then I sent her wild and she
read wild and she was like okay I'll do
it comfortably and then we got going to
bed yannick I love her I love her as an
actor I love her as a human being as my
friend my producer you know and it's
grown more and more as we've gotten to
know each other which has been so
beautiful but there it's a funny thing
there are a few people in this life when
we do the same thing that you know each
other even from afar and you really feel
like you know them and I always felt
that about Reese and maybe being from
the south and southern Mama's and
working with Alexander Payne and people
that we share in common we felt like we
knew each other somehow so that was a
cool way in but you know as these guys
have spoken about when it comes to
Cheryl she she requires the truth
from everyone there and this isn't just
about actors this is about her
cinematographer the production designer
the costumer everything not only had to
feel authentic but we were also in love
with her book that we wanted it to feel
like the truth and so there was a
delicacy on this set that was so
beautiful that's sort of unparalleled
from experiences I've had where everyone
has this like quiet longing to protect
Cheryl and to protect her mother and so
you know to hurl my love toward this
woman with the cellular memory that
Cheryl holds as she's standing in the
corner of her love of her mother was
just a gift